President Biden says he's sending a
stark warning to Iran after deadly
strikes in Syria the president said he
does not see conflict with Iran but he
vowed the U.S would respond forcefully
to protect Americans CBS News has
learned there have been three more
attacks on U.S military bases in Syria
since the U.S launched a retaliatory
airstrike after a suspected Iranian
drone killed an American contractor
Thursday at least six other Americans
were wounded David Martin reports from
the Pentagon
the aftermath of a strike by American
Jets against what U.S officials called
the headquarters of the iranian-backed
Islamic revolutionary guards in eastern
Syria
the pilots observed a secondary
explosion a sign they also hid an ammo
dump be prepared for a strike forcefully
protect our people that's exactly what
happened last night President Biden
ordered the strike Thursday as he flew
to Canada aboard Air Force One after a
drone hit an American base in
northeastern Syria
at the time the air defense system
surrounding the base was not in full
operation and military officials are now
investigating whether that is why the
Drone got through we are very confident
that based on the forensics based on the
intelligence analysis that we've done
that it was of Iranian origin there are
still about 900 American troops in Syria
working with local fighters to go after
remnants of the Isis Terror Network
but that has exposed them to attacks by
Iran's Islamic revolutionary guards
they're clearly trying to run us out of
Syria at the very least the commander of
U.S forces in the Middle East tallied up
the attack since the start of the Biden
Administration there has been a number
since uh one January 2021 the number is
about 78 times that we have been
attacked Iranian drones are also being
used by Russia against Ukraine one of
several potential flashpoints between
the U.S and Iran U.S officials say Iran
is only months away from being able to
field a nuclear weapon but Joint Chiefs
chairman General Mark milley testified
this week the U.S has plans to prevent
that and we the United States military
have developed multiple options for our
national leadership to consider if or
when Iran ever decides to develop an
actual nuclear weapon it's not clear
whether the government of Iran directly
orders these attacks on American bases
or just encourages them for CBS Saturday
morning David Martin at the Pentagon